this man knows broadcasting entering his
40th season broadcasting Dallas Cowboys
football on the Cowboys radio network
and he knows Cowboys
he's Brad champ back here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Brad how are you
I'm great
how do you think Witten's gonna do in
the booth Brad I think jason witten will
probably be good at whatever he chooses
to do I did not know that he had an
interest in broadcasting and I'm not
sure until fairly recently that he knew
it but I do know his personality his
intelligence his work ethic and I can't
think of any reason why he would not
succeed well in a way that Romo never
really showed a side of himself that
suddenly came into view like the guy at
the end of the bar who was screaming and
yelling at the set instead he's just
screaming and yelling through his set
next to Nance that would became so
popular and he's Emmy nominated this
year is there a side of Witten that we
haven't seen Brad or is that the way
that we're gonna get no no no I Rome oh
and I CRO Aikman in there too and the
difference between Witten and both of
them in terms of public persona is his
willingness to stand there after games
and once a week and take every single
question and do it in reasonably good
humor those other two guys their
patience for doing that kind of work
then in terms of what you're talking
about a broadcast personality that will
translate and is there another side to
them yeah absolutely and what people who
don't know em and see and only on the
field rich have not seen are two things
one is a burning competitiveness he is
as competitive as any player I have ever
seen in 40 years and the other is a deep
insightful knowledge of every aspect of
the game he sees it the way quarterbacks
do because of how he studied it and
that's
coverages blocking schemes the whole
thing that makes a play work and then
combined with that he has a really
unusual appreciation and knowledge of
the history of the game I wasn't set
with him on a flight last year was a
fairly long flight before the flight the
configuration of where the seats were
added him in a place where he had a seat
next to him and we may have been going
to Washington because Vernon Davis was
really going well at the time and there
were a couple of conversations going on
in coaches and some other broadcasters
about who stands where in the all-time
ranking of tight ends and so I said well
there's a guy who's got an opinion maybe
let me see what you know a lot of guys a
lot of times guys don't know anything
about history so I sat down next to him
I said if you ready to study it is he oh
yeah and we don't have time now for me
to tell you going back to John Mackay
and Mike Ditka his understanding of why
his list of the top five tight ends
would be whatever was and specifically
what every guy could do and didn't do
and wasn't asked to do and how it was
different now and frankly I had never
had that kind of a historical
conversation with him I didn't realize
that his knowledge and passion for all
of it was so deep when you put those
things all better to me the only thing
he's going to have to master is the art
of saying it in the number of seconds
you have available as an analyst between
that Brad Shaam voice the Cowboys here
what about the excitement passion energy
from from yeah yeah don't be different
from Romo it'd be different from Rome
entirely different from Romo pretty much
right you didn't think that I don't mean
you do I mean none of us run that aiklen
was going to show that and yeah trust me
they'll be fine a brad Sherman the Honda
Insight a report here on the Rich Eisen
show so okay let's get to other aspects
of the Cowboys organization football
wise
this does this leave this team hamstrung
a little bit at this position where they
were really trying to make him think
twice about going in the booth Brett I
think that from an X's and O's who lines
up and how do you use your personnel
they're better with him than without him
but he'd be the first one to tell you
that he's not the physical player that
he was three or four or five years ago
so they they will have capable bodies
Jeff Swain is a pretty good player and
Blake jar one's got a chance to be a
pretty good player and the young fellow
they drafted with Stanford Schultz I
haven't seen him but a little bit of
tape I've seen he that chance to be a
pretty good player and you know the
coaching staff will be challenged to
find ways to use the talents of the
tight ends they have as well as the
facts they have and the wide receivers
they have and find ways to take up some
of that slack where they will definitely
suffer as partly in his experience
getting on he maybe not you may not be
able to get as as open as quickly and go
as far after a catch as he used to but
he still knew how to do all of the above
and the other guys are going to have to
work to that point through experience
and in the leadership department that
there's it's you're replaceable their
leadership and example and here's how
you behave in practice and meetings and
with the media after you win and here's
how you do it after a loss and here's
how you bond together in the OTAs and
training can-am got anybody like that so
that's going to now fall to Prescott in
my opinion and and to guys like Zack
Martin and Travis Frederick and to guys
like Sean Lee and and he's going to have
to find a couple of guys like that but
they're they've got a huge leadership
void right now and how that translates
onto the field is partly going to depend
on the coaching staff and partly going
to depend on those other players
figuring out how to take up some of the
slide
forced the Cowboys Brad sham here in the
Honda inside a report let's get to Dez
Bryant here why did the Cowboys wait as
long as they did to release him when we
find out from Wilma clay the assistant
director of player personnel when he
appeared locally there in the Metroplex
said that it was a football decision the
inability to win one on one to win
downfield if that was the reasoning then
wasn't that apparent at the outset of
free agency as opposed to how long it
took to part ways with Dez right it'd be
a great question for you to ask Wilma
play in Stephen Jones my guess is that
the reason they took so long and and and
well Wells not gonna lie but he none of
those guys race you know it nobody's
gonna tell the whole story if there's
anything that they didn't like about him
or felt like they didn't want to put up
with it they're not gonna say that I I
think my personal guess is and it's
based on a couple of conversations with
some of the decision makers in the last
I don't know a month or so my personal
guess is that the reason it took so long
is they weren't sure at every level of
the decision-making tree that they
wanted to let him go and they they may
have kept looking for reasons to make a
different decision or an amended
decision and ultimately they decided
that they couldn't do that and I don't
know that if they had it to do over
again they might not like to have
different timing and and maybe they
wouldn't maybe they're fine with it but
when you asked why did it take so long
what was the timing if that was the
reason I would submit that there there
was a layer of reasons that was part of
it and I'm just not sure that they
really had convinced themselves all of
them that they wanted to let him go
until they did dare I say that reading
between the lines that sounds like Jerry
just couldn't bring himself to do it I'm
totally fine had no choice I cannot read
through your eyeglasses voiced the
Cowboys here on the Rich Eisen show and
then
the draft there do you think that the
Eagles traded up to get the tight end
that they wanted and then even worse had
david akers troll the organization in in
Jerry's house while doing it
Bret no I don't think that I don't think
that's the guy the Cowboys were looking
at no and and the fact that his name is
Dallas I think that's that and David
Akers got a little shrill for my taste
and trying to one-up Drew Pearson but I
but I do admire the spirit and there is
all of them join joined in it but I
think that they I think they would have
loved to have had veto veía well I'll
tell you the truth when they were
sitting there at the draft got to 12 I
kept saying to mine I was just sit in
the stands watch and I said Jerry call
Tampa give him something yet bad then
Tampa took they are so what do you know
and then after that I think that there
that sold on Vander Ashe obviously if
they were going to move for anybody it
would not have been for the tight end it
might have been for James and I think
that the safety who went you know much
later than anybody thought and I think
that that at some point in their after
veía left they probably had a couple of
more long conversations maybe Amazon
will do another series next year we can
find out a year nice but I think that
they I think they probably had some
conversations about okay James Evander
Esch what do you like and I think they
like Vander a that much it was not about
this idea Brad always enjoy our chats
always dude thanks for coming and giving
some insight today on the day that
Witten takes down the star and then goes
into the the booth that dandy Don
Meredith first inhabited it's
unbelievable how the Cowboys keep on
keep on sending guys into the booth
appreciate the time it's like thanks
thanks to the call Brad always
appreciate that yeah boys underscore box
vo X the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience